just one more thing I got it down it is
crazy that arrow is coming to a close
when you look back at the first time of
trying on your suit what comes to mind
when I think about trying on the suit
I don't think about trying on the suit
would say I think about being fitted for
the suit because I went to calling out
woods home she did the original Aero
suit and I was looking up there and I
was like oh that's cool look at that
those are framed things stating that
you've been nominated for an Oscar I'm
like that's the coolest thing that I've
ever seen and then I kept my gaze going
and I saw three Academy Awards so I'm
like so I remember that I remember that
very much and I remember the first thing
that they put me in was like work boots
they're like army boots like this is not
I've got a I've gotta do stuff they're
like what do you suggest oh my god
trained in Nike freeze
can you make Nike freeze it then I go we
can do that will we be seeing the Salmon
Ladder
last season yeah in the premiere there's
shirtless Aaron ladder in the premiere
oh why thank you you're welcome
I know that Greg tells you a lot about
what's coming up for arrow and Oliver
and that you know the entire arc of the
season when he painted the picture for
you what was your initial reaction well
we've actually been in discussions
basically since the middle of season six
about all of us exit and how that
ultimately happens so I know it
I actually know less about this year
than I typically know and I've been
excited to you know every episode it's
it's really been like every episode
feels like a special episode like
Episode one feels like
it's just an ode to season one and
episode two really leans on season three
and episode three is just all about
family but they all say they all feel
like they have a theme like you know
when they did it from on they go on a
very special episode of that's what
every episode this year feels like but I
actually don't know a great deal beyond
episode three right now you tease that
we can expect a happy ending
can you elaborate on that that's just
because I love all serious finales I
love Seinfeld I like lost I think I
think it's gonna be I think that it's
gonna be happy because there's there's a
resolution it doesn't mean that that
doesn't mean that it won't be sad but I
personally think that it's a happy
ending it is for me it's been so nice to
see Kat McNamara join the show and play
your daughter Mia what are the chances
we could actually get a Mia and Oliver
scene I think they're pretty good
yeah what's it been like welcoming her
into the family that's wonderful
I haven't gotten to work with her yet
obviously but I've watched her work a
bunch
I watched her do a fantastic scene last
night in episode 803 because I was
behind the monitors with with Katie
Cassidy because she's directing and
that's great and actually it's been the
most time with her that I have thus far
on the premiere because she shadowed as
she shadowed James Bamford directing and
that's basically that's kind of
emblematic of cat as a whole like she
loves the industry she's wise beyond her
years at her age I was an idiot she's
and she's very smart very capable
she's very mature she's great I adore
her
when we last chatted at Comic Con you'd
said you're gonna go see Emily's play in
New York how was it everyone made fun of
me at the play because they all got up
to give her standing ovations and they
looked at me and I was clapping but I
wasn't standing cuz I was crying and I
wanted to stand up in front of Emily's
I'm so proud of her
doing a play in New York like man that's
a thing it's a grind and I think her
last shows actually tonight so very
proud of her and she's wonderful and I
can't wait to see what she does
Thanks well I'm hoping that she will
come back to arrow for one more episode
what are those conversations like
between the two of you
those aren't conversations that the two
of us have to have yeah as a fan of the
show does that sound weird so yeah I'm a
fan of I'm a fan of of our show yeah I I
would love her to come back as her
friend I respect whatever her decision
is I think probably not but I love that
you guys have such a great friendship
and that you've been able to off that of
all over this whole season David said it
feels like a different show this year
without her there she's one of my best
friends and it's it's it's uh
it's tough not having her there because
Oliver is it sometimes and and and the
levity of Emily's character you know
always it was there I'm actually
purposefully trying this year to not
take scenes where I might be a little
morose and because we'd always have the
juxtaposition of felicity we don't have
that this year so believe it or not
here's a scoop for you I tell a joke or
two this white yeah try to be humorous
it doesn't work I heard a rumor that I
heard a rumor that the character in the
comics was quick-witted and sort of
funny so we're trying to incorporate
that you know right before the show's
done
get a little bit of Barry Allen in there
no get a little bit of like cannon
Oliver Queen all right I like that I
like that have you already started
looking around set and figuring out what
you're gonna steal people keep asking me
this question I don't want to I don't
want to steal anything from this what
would you like to be gifted and to take
home to keep I want to take a suit I'm
and when I say I want to take a suit I'm
going to take a seat yeah I have the bow
from the pilots era give it back to me
at Comic Con this year I have that
whatsoever oh here's a scoop for you one
of the reasons that they want me to give
it back is because in season eight
Oliver just using his season which
magically appears because the dark lads
are broken and I love that you're giving
me those little nuggets that you haven't
given anyone else you want to know how
the series ends yes I do
hey I kept I kept the secret that cat
was coming on for a year I know you're
good we'll talk after this is over you
guys are gearing up for the most
ambitious crossover series I think in
television history five hours five parts
how are you feeling about that and what
can you tease for the fans do you think
that it actually is like is it the most
ambitious crossover that yeah I mean
cool and now we're adding in a sixth
show even though we're not doing a sixth
hour so Marc Guggenheim tried to explain
the crossover to me and he was so
excited that it was just just consonant
sounds coming out of his mouth that that
there was no sentence structure
whatsoever the only thing that I can
tease is that there are no rules and I'm
playing two characters well lastly as
arrow if I buried the lede oh I know
that was good but you told me that a
Comic Cons that's fine
okay yeah we're good I told you how to
party right or did I tell you on top
were we being recorded no we're being
recorded
oh good we're live good good yes I saw
it I saw that characters costume today
it was great mm-hmm you try not that you
hear concept art for something that I'm
gonna be doing in the classroom is it a
character that we know
nope never appeared on screen before oh
I like that
lastly as as arrow is getting ready to
leave us we are getting to know a new
superhero with the introduction of bat
woman played by the lovely Ruby Rose
what does it mean for you to have been
able to kind of spark this whole
franchise and now we have our first
openly lesbian superhero coming to the
series it's weird when people like how
do you feel about starting this I didn't
I was lucky to be first yeah it's always
been a priority for me Emily was my
first guest star but then when caity
lotz came on in season 2 or when Grant
was in those two episodes 8 and 9 in the
season 2 or when in season 4 we wove
back in Brandon and Katie to help with
legends to get him to go with Gotham
City and introduce Ruby's character in
the crossover
I just tried to I just try to be a good
host
that's all and I tell everyone that
comes on I go you don't need it because
you're here already but if you ever need
anything from me
[Music]